so let's get back and talk about the
strong winds whipping through the valley
late last night into this morning now
those powerful gusts they cause some
power outages perhaps you were one of
those folks some of though
you're waking up with debris snapped
tree limbs in your neighborhood you're
trying to navigate boxes and trash in
the road i mean it's like an obstacle
course out there hector mejia joining us
live near the convention center and las
vegas boulevard with the latest on any
outages this morning hector good morning
it really is like an obstacle course
good morning guys you know on my drive
here to work i saw some trash just
flying there across some lanes there and
this morning fewer than 800 customers
remain without power that's according to
envy energy's website you know who else
will be busy today tree service
companies and this is why check out this
tree ripped from the ground and then
boom it went on its side this is here in
our parking lot yesterday's winds
reached a high of over 60 miles an hour
in some parts of the valley according to
the national weather service and check
this out here's something we don't see
every day the north end of the las vegas
strip completely in the dark after the
power went out it's back on this morning
but we heard from guests last night at
the strat who said the lights went out
in the rooms the casino area though was
still active thanks to backup generators
and yesterday with the powerful winds at
at times as many as 11 000 outages were
reported but thankfully this morning
crews are out they're making progress
and they're restoring power this morning
if you find any damage in your own
neighborhood go ahead and share pictures
with us if you can safely reporting live
this morning hector mejia live local now